it's
okay
so that's why it's uh
let's see if he's right
now
foreign
exactly
foreign
foreign
stocks I just want to make an
announcement for the last Workshop of
this program which is the workshop on
societal considerations that Workshop is
soliciting posters and today is the
deadline for submitting posters so
please do pass this message
okay so coming back to this Workshop
today is the last day we'll be having
two talks today half a day first talk
would be by Gabriel Farina
um he's a CMU and it's a recipe to
Facebook Fellowship new room space paper
award and there really has multiple
streams of very exciting work including
you know first order based methods
regret-based methods for equilibrium
finding many interesting statements to
make about extensor firm games like code
red and course qualitative extensive on
Games Etc today is going to talk about
no regret learning for General context
games
thanks so much everybody for uh being
here so first of all let me say you know
like this work uh was like a
collaboration of a lot of people uh
amazing cultures uh so you know because
also all of them but without you know
like with that uh let me just jump right
into uh the talk and I want to start
baby by telling you uh what you can
expect from this talk just like not just
like a takeaway and then we're gonna
Deep dive into it kind of like the map
behind it and feel free to you know like
interrupt it at the moment
also a recent line of work uh has
established uncoupled learning dynamics
that when all the players employ in a
game uh they're such that every player's
regret after any team repetitions grows
only politically into expertise time or
the number of repetitions
and you know this has
um implications for equilibrium finding
this leads to some of the fastest known
methods to compute equilibrium large
games however so far these results have
only been limited to certain classes of
games that have structured strategy
spaces mostly normal form games that's
where I think a lot of the research has
been driven
there are some results about extensive
fund games that I will briefly talk
about but you know like the I guess the
point that I want to make is that many
fundamental models in economics and
multi-aging systems require going Beyond
those kind of like simple like normal
foreign game settings and instead
required looking at a general convex
compact strategy sets
right so this kind of leads to this
natural question which is can we attain
uh Paul logarithmic in time regret per
player in general convex and combat uh
strategy sets while at the same time
retaining efficient strategy updates I
mean you could imagine that if you have
a general compact set maybe you
discretize maybe you find the net and
you convert it into the normal form game
and then you use one of the Dynamics
that get that guarantee polarity make
regret but you don't want to do that
that's that's very expensive
um so we want both efficient strategy
updates and Polaroid make time regret
for any kind of just like convex uh kind
of strategy set
and uh I guess like the whole point of
what I'm going to talk about today is
that actually the answer is yes so we
answered this in positive and in
particular we give an uncoupled learning
algorithm that guarantees logarithmic in
t uh purple your regret
um and that holds uh for General complex
compact games and one nice feature of
this Dynamic source is that you know
like if it turns out that not everybody
is using the same Dynamics in the game
then they kind of like gracefully fall
back to square root of T So except
linearity uh regarding that in that case
yes let's just ask um you don't want to
do the Nets because computationally
expensive or because you would need a
couple of Dynamics to do it because it
would be computational expensive
uh yeah that's a good question I think
so uh I guess it also boils down as to
like what is the feedback uh like these
Dynamics will be in the full feedback so
I guess like uh you know like in general
I guess like the Bandit cases is a
little bit uh I guess like more
complicated
um but uh yeah but yeah I I would say
probably mostly computational
um
cool right so like I was saying you know
like we we're guarantee that if every
player is using these Dynamics they get
uh they can attain logarithmic into
regret per player uh in adversarial
settings uh they fall back to square
root of T So sub linear yes
right right yeah I'll talk about the
assumptions like we assume concave
losses
um and you know like smoothness great
like you know smooth gradients all of
that
um right so you can think of of this as
you know I think there's like there has
been a lot of work in online complex
optimization like in in the general
compact case where you don't assume any
any structure about the environment and
you know they are they you know like
it's known that you can attain sibling
regret this is kind of like adding One
Step which is if you know that everybody
is using the same Dynamics can achieve
better than square root of T and the
answer is you can do logarithmic and T
for any uh convex set yes do the players
need to know how smooth the game is or
some information about brother is that's
a good question uh yes or no I mean like
the I guess like the way the I will
present the math assumes that it but
then you could imagine some form of uh
kind of like binary search right but but
then there has to be some form of
coordination which I mean at the same
time you know you're already assuming
when you say everybody's using the same
learning Dynamics so you could imagine
that part of the Dynamics itself is kind
of like to do this backtracking uh so
you can like join me
well also let me uh you know like
because this is like for General convex
sets uh there's a question is to kind of
like what kind of like Oracle access do
you have to the compact set when you do
the optimization so we have uh two
models
um if we have access to what we call a
local proximal Oracle for the set
um which you can think of like these
guys like a proximal step uh Oracle then
we guarantee that every iteration of
these learning Dynamics takes log log T
time
um right so kind of like close to
constant almost
um if you only have access to a linear
optimization Oracle Which is less
powerful then we get Polo polynomial in
t uh
cost per duration
and then we also mentioned that in
special cases where private results
apply our algorithm improves over the
state of the order redbones uh both like
either in terms of the dependence or
number of iterations or in terms of the
dependence on the dimension of the
strategy sets right so we actually also
give nice improvements in the normal
form accessible cases for some of the uh
you know dependencies
cool okay so I guess that gives like
they didn't come like that an overview
of what we're going to talk about so let
me also give you some history and
context about this this problem it has
kind of like a a rich uh history so
first of all program minimization
clearly it's like a celebrated framework
that has been Central in the development
of online learning and multi-agent
systems the idea of programming musician
is that you know like you say that
you've learned in a game
um or like you've learned how to play a
game when looking back uh every player
does not strongly wish that they play
differently that's what we mean by the
player has learned
um and I guess regret come back and
codes this mathematically
um and if we you know kind of like zoom
out and we just like try to find reasons
to care about organization I think
there's like at least three different
scenarios the first one is that well you
know like this idea of learning in games
is such a natural
um kind of like idea and regret to such
natural notion of performance that
perhaps you care about programming
musician just like for the sake of it
you know like it's just like it's a
natural model
um and the good news clearly is that you
know no regret algorithms uh that are
designed for fully adversarial
environments they guarantee something
that regret exists so that's a nice nice
feature
um the second reason why you might care
about regularization is that it might be
a good model for the behavior of the
system that you're modeling like maybe
an option like there's like some results
in economics they say the regret
minimization might be a good model of
your system but what I want to focus
more in this talk is the connection that
there exists between learning in games
and computation of gaming theoretic
equilibria
um right it's it's known that um when
all the players are programming then uh
the kind of like empirical frequency of
play converges to a course correlated
equilibrium a multiplayer you know some
games it's all like no matter the number
of players uh also like General some
um one thing that's to be said about uh
course credit technical Libra is the
approximation error in particular is
tied to the maximum individual regret
we'll talk about this quality of Maximum
individual regrets soon
um and also let me mention that a
special case of this uh kind of
convergence guarantee is that in two
players there are some games
um in particular we can use kind of like
soft play of No Regret learning Dynamics
to uh conversion right which is kind of
important for you know just like playing
games for example
right so I will want to like for this
talk I'll mostly focus on this third
idea like the important connections to
game theoretic equilibrium and the idea
of how that works again is that players
training against each other in self-play
and
um currently these kind of like learning
based methods are the state of the art
for large games by far
um and they've had remarkable practical
success uh they're being used in kind of
recent results in AI they think about
poker but also like recently like
Stratego
um you know they're like diplomacy
there's like an Abbey like people have
been using these actually to play
against humans and they work very well
and you know like if if you squint your
eyes you know like we're just saying
okay we care about regular musician it's
designed to handle food adversarial
settings that's amazing uh but then we
just say okay maybe we care about uh
convergence to you know like equilibria
in self-play and then if we look at it
you know self-play learning is far from
fully unpredictable adversary like you
know that other agents are trying to
learn themselves
um right so perhaps the fully
adversarial setting is not kind of like
the right model if you actually care
about self-player agents and this makes
the question like what performance
guarantees can be obtained for self-play
in general games right like if you can
like move away from this full
adversarial idea and just say okay maybe
I know that everybody is doing software
how fast can you learn and you know like
the question I guess was first looked
into by uh that's Italian 2011 for uh
two players or some Matrix Games and
since then there has been considerable
interest in extending guarantees to more
general settings so let me just like
mention a few
um
so uh you know jacketal and Rocklin and
sridoran uh they pioneered around 2012
2013 uh the framework of optimism or
learning with predictable sequences uh
surganis uh like as a nurse liver award
where they you know like like of course
where they crystallized the rvu property
um and then in turn enabled uh dynamics
that have to do the one fourth instead
of to do one-half per player regret in
convex games right so this is like for
General convex games t to the one fourth
um Channel pink recently in 2020 uh
improved the 2214 to the one sixth but
only for two player games
and then most recently in 2022 last year
umakis and
um
sorry there's like a one name but like
that's right uh shows that I think
that's a wrong reference there's like
also a Max officials and on the on the
paper
um but shows that uh images games one
can achieve
um politic regrets so look to the fourth
so we went from to the one four to the
one six and then now unlock the fourth
uh by using the optimistic
multiplicative ways of data algorithm
and this is like kind of like with like
a breakthrough at the time because you
know like it's an international
improvement over the guarantees that
were so far uh obtained using
traditional techniques within another
framework right like it was polynomial
before and now it's polarizmic
um
and uh I guess we've done some work with
some collaborators uh extending the
optimistic multiplicative weights update
result uh by showing that in certain
classes of polyhedral games like not
Matrix games anymore but like political
games which includes uh extension from
games one can run optimistic
multiplicative words update on the
exponentially many vertex vertices of
these polyhedral domains in polynomial
time thanks to Kernel trick and we call
this algorithm kernelized optimistic
moving negative words update so
basically what you can do is you can
convert your game to a matrix game
fundamentally and still handle it
efficiently
uh and then piggyback on the look of the
fourth thing and regret kind of like
black box reduction
um I've done some work uh with uh
Johannes and other uh extending the uh
technique uh of uh
to uh swap regret instead of
um you know external regret in Matrix
Games and then most recently pedora
settle proposed
um learning dynamics that guarantee log
T so not not locked the force but log T
regret but only for a sub sequence of
iterates in Matrix Games
right and so finally what we share in
this paper is again like a lot of regret
for General context games right so if
you know if you were like summarize kind
of like the the path that led to here
this is what uh it kind of would look
like so
um you know like we started with the I
guess like certain result and then there
was like optimistic multiplicity with
update recently uh this is like all for
like multiplayer so I'm like committing
the two player only results for example
like the t216 that was only for two
players
cool
all right let me also mention that we
actually have implemented the Dynamics
um so just just to make sure you know
like that actually you know everything
looked like the theory predicted so
these are some experiment results I mean
they're not important for the talk but I
just wanted to show you you know like we
have a logarithmic access uh x-axis
right so you see that indeed like this
Dynamics kind of like 10 10 to like
flatten up as like lines right so you
have actually look d uh Progressive
player which you know was kind of
satisfying to see you know the the
practice matching the theory
cool okay and with that I guess we can
uh start talking about complex games and
how these Dynamics are constructed so
uh first let me introduce the idea of a
convex game and this will answer also
like some of the
uh the questions that I have to release
ahead
um so in so how do we Define a complex
game well an end player complex game has
two components well it well first of all
it has n players but then it has two
things like the first property that we
test is that every player plays from a
convex and compact strategy set which I
will always denote x i you can think of
this as uh the set of mixed strategies
that the player has for example like in
a normal phone game which is a special
case of a convex game uh XI would be
kind of like the probability Simplex
over the the action say rock paper
scissors
um right so every player plays from a
convex and compact strategy set and then
the second thing is that the utility
function of every player uh is
continuously differentiable uh it is
concave
um right so that's the first assumption
um so the convex games are also
sometimes called concave games so it's a
little bit of uh yeah you can pick
um
the second property of these utility
functions is that they have bounded
gradients
um right so the gradients cannot the
gradients of the utility on the
utilities very player cannot explode
um and then we assume some uh
lipstickness or lipstick continuity of
the gradient right so we assume that
basically if the if you have two
strategies X Prime they're not too far
away then the gradients of the utilities
will also not be too far away
so this is the the all like all of the
technical assumptions that we make about
uh these games and then the results in
in the stock will apply to any game that
satisfies this and in particular now
we'll go through like a small list of
games that satisfy this uh the I guess
like the less surprising one is normal
phone games uh right like you know like
I'm sure we're all familiar with
non-reformal games but just you know
like just in case you know a normal form
game is a game that looks like rock
paper scissors fundamentally everybody
has a finite set of actions uh players
pick one action
um potentially like from a kind of they
randomize the the choice they play the
action simultaneously so there's like no
turns and then depending on the
combination of actions a payoff is given
to every player
um right so we'll call the action set AI
uh for player I
and then you know like when you want to
view a normal form game as a complexity
the way you do it is that uh you know
like the strategy said that every player
has in this combat complex
representation is just the probability
Simplex over spanned by the actions
right so all the probability
distributions over the action set and
the utility of a player uh is the
expectation right so it's kind of like
this multilinear function that depends
on the probability distributions that
are played by the players
and you know like because this function
is multi-linear it's it's easy to see
that the gradients of the utility
function are bounded by the maximum
payoff and furthermore uh the smoothness
of the gradient is kind of like for free
uh this kind of you know total variation
distance
cool so normal Forum games can like
prototypical example of convex games
uh excessive form games
um you know are another example uh of
convex game excessive form games are
games that are played in the game tree
so this capture games like uh poker go
Bridge basically whatever uh most
interaction in the real world could be
modeled this way
um in particular excessive form games
are able to capture turns simultaneous
moves the plastic moves for example like
stochastic move could be and like you
draw like a card at random uh that's
kind of like a major move
um and most importantly they're able to
capture imperfect information
um which usually you know like if you
look in the figure like a discount like
gray boxes have appeared around notes
basically you can kind of like uh in
this in accessible games you can
basically just say oh like players don't
really distinguish between different
nodes and they're having perfect
information
um it turns out that even with imperfect
information extensive from games are
convex games
um the strategy space of every player is
a complex polytope which is called the
sequence front polytope right will not
talk about the details as to how it's
constructed but you know it has
polynomial constraints we know
everything about it
um utilities are again multilinear
um right so which means that for free
just like a normal from games to get uh
you know smooth gradients and Boundary
gradients all of the good properties
that we need for this to be effectively
a complex game
yeah let me mention more example of
complex games uh we have splitable
routing games uh there every player has
some flow to route from a source to a
destination and some undirected graph
every Edge is associated with the
latency function the maps can like the
flow that passes through the edge to
some latency in this case if you want to
see this as a complex game uh the
strategy set of every player would be
all possible ways of splitting flow into
paths from sources destination so this
is a complex polytope and under suitable
uh restrictions on the Liberty function
then you can also show that uh these
games uh satisfy the complex game
definition so it's bounded smooth
gradients
uh I guess like the last game that or
like classic of games that I will uh
talk about is uh Chrono competition
games their players are actually firms
every firm or player I decides some
quantity of some good to produce from
some integral for example
um a cost function for every player a
science a production cost the given
quantity that the player has selected
and then the price of the good is
determined by The Joint choice of
quantity so that that is instead
determined by how much quantity all the
players have
picked and you told your player I or
firm I
is defined as the symbol function you
know like it's like the production cost
basically uh minus the the price at
which you can solve the good
and uh you know there's like an
important case in criminal competition
games which is uh concave and smooth uh
function uis which fundamentally brings
down this problem to a complex game
right so here you would have the
strategy so that's very players like
intervals and then you have complete
small amount of gradients
right so I guess we talked about this
full class of games channel forum
extensive form I guess we talked about
splittable writing games we talked about
Chrono competitions hopefully at this
point you're convinced that you know
like convex games are kind of like a
meaningful class of games that we care
about
okay briefly before going to kind of
like more of the core of the math as to
how these Dynamics work uh let me just
like fix some ideas about the learning
setup in convex Games first of all you
know like as always with the programming
musician we're talking about repeated
interactions
um at every time C every player outputs
a strategy from their set so we will
always denote strategies uh with with X
and
um you know the subscript will always be
the player the superscript in
parenthesis will always be time
and then you know after every player has
output other strategies at Mt then
everybody observes the gradient of their
own utility so this goes back to Nika's
question
um right like this will be the uh
contact of what is called the kind of
full information feedback model
um
so uh in particular you know like the
utility like the utility Vector player I
is like the gradient of their own
utility given the choice of uh
strategies for all the players the
gradient only with respect to of course
the structure of the player
cool and then the canonical measure or
performance of each player is Regret
right so I've been talking about regret
this whole time so uh you know like this
like the definition of regret that we're
going to use like standard uh definition
of regret basically we just look uh you
know like if we could go back in time
and just like pick the best trick
strategy x-star in hindsight what is the
difference between the utility that they
would have achieved minus
um you know whatever uh xit has
accumulated over time
cool any question about the this is like
the last slide for the kind of like the
setting uh or the setup so if you have
like any question before we delve into
contract Dynamics
all right so I guess we did uh let me
tell you philosophically how you can
achieve you know this locative regret
and then we'll talk about how to
actually Implement that plan uh but I'll
talk about uh I guess like three things
the first thing is I want to talk a
little bit about uh really what rvu
bounds enable and what they don't uh in
particular I guess like the spoiler is
that uh our view bounds are very good
when you care about the sum of the
player's regrets like the social regret
but no guarantees or at least I have
like three question marks because at
least I don't know any guarantees but
maybe there is something that could be
said but I think currently uh that's
kind of like a question
um on individual regret yes so what is
the full form of rbu again oh we'll talk
about the exactly the okay so rvu just
like historically uh that is the I guess
you talked about it when it came to the
work by sergancetal right so like in the
2015 Europe stripper that they have
where they are kind of like the first to
give like they still do one-fourth uh
like Dynamics in soft play like doing
afford to create Dynamics and soft play
they do it through this idea of like the
rvu with red bounds and we'll talk about
my question is rbu stands forward oh oh
it means regret bounded by variation in
utilities but actually it's a little bit
more than that so it's more than the
variation in utilities we'll talk about
it but but yeah but you can think of it
as just like a type of like predictive
regret kind of like guarantee
um
cool right so basically like the first
thing was uh what are viewbounds enabled
and what they don't uh part two is what
would be enough then to enable uh this
conversion from constant social to
ideally constant individual regret
guarantees will not quite get to consent
but you know like we'll we'll talk about
what could get there and then you know
like after talking about all this
hopefully this will you know like give
like a good blueprint for what's to come
so let me start with our view bounds uh
entity of social regrets so an rvu bound
is
a regret statement of an algorithm that
looks like this roughly right and the I
will always use the less than with the
kind of like a approx thing to just mean
that I'm kind of like uh removing
constants that are kind of like
Irrelevant for the discussion and they
would just you know become like clutter
the math but but not really the idea so
fundamentally what it means is that if
we have a learning rate ETA then the
regret roughly looks like you have a
constant over ETA right so if it is too
small that's not good because regret
then you know like the red bound is very
high
um plus the learning rate times
basically the the amount of variation
that has happened in the utilities of
the player
right so that's why it's called the
regret bounded by variation in utility
uh right so like the variation of
utilities like the second part
um and then we have minus the inverse of
the step size times how much variation
has there like has been like has
happened in the utilities so in the
strategies of the player right so it's
like regret bounded by variation of
utilities minus variation of strategies
if you want right and one thing that's
interesting is that that last term if
ETA is very small like if the learning
rate is small is very negative potential
right so it's kind of like a nice
feature
um
so let me mention this like regret like
our view type bounds are very powerful
uh and in fact the fact that you can
even write statements like that
immediately implies that the social
regret which means the sum of
regrettable players is at most a uh
constant independent of time and the
idea for that is pretty simple uh if you
this is kind of like basically what
happened in the paper by sarganis in
2015 like if you use the smoothness of
the utilities then the middle sum can be
bounded you know like by uh you know
kind of like the variation of the
utility because you know the uit minus
uit minus one basically is the
difference in utility that has happened
given that the strategies were XD and XD
minus one right so the variation that
has happened in the utility because we
assume lipstick smoothness of the of the
uh utility gradients is upper bounded by
the sum on the right
and if you plug that into the middle
term and then you sum over all the
regrets you end up with something that
looks like you know well we are counting
the one over ETA the first term in the
our view bound and times because one
monster player then
um we are counting n times the middle
term and then for every player we have
that minus one over ETA times the sum of
the variations so basically this there's
some like sum of variation of strategies
you can you know collect and then you
have this term and ETA L squared minus
one Rita in front of it and then like we
said you know like if it is small this
like this factor in front can be
negative right so you can just
completely throw away like the very the
social variation of of strategy or what
is called like the social Square path
length and you end up with this lesson
recall and Rita which is a constant that
does not depend on it
okay so this is kind of like the the big
idea behind I guess uh or like one of
the big Ideas behind the 2015 paper by
Sir Gardens
okay any question about the
general account like idea basically like
our viewbound I guess implies uh
constant social progress this is kind of
like the message of this slide
but you know like that social regret
what can be said about individual regret
and um unfortunately
convergence to course correlated
equilibrium multiplayer games is driven
not by the social regret but the maximum
individual regret
right so the fact that we have a
guarantee that says oh the sum of the
regret is at most constant might tell us
nothing about the individual regret and
and if this sounds like weird at this
point I think
one thing that can always you know like
confuse that regret can be negative and
in fact can be very negative like if if
you have this predictive learning
Dynamics you might Advocate that some of
the regrets is is constant like is it
most a constant but then one player has
learned so well that the regret is so
negative and some other player might be
kind of just like being left behind and
so they have a huge regret and then you
know like the sum may be still small but
then you're not converging to a course
called equilibrium right so that's why
uh you know social regret and individual
regret are very different and they
require different techniques
at this point you know you might be
wondering you know like what do rvu
bounds tell us about individual regrets
and they tell us two things
um the first thing is that you know like
our view ones are still valid and in
particular if you ignore the third term
like the minus one Rita some of the uh
distances and then you bound the middle
term like we did before this expression
is still valid for the regret of player
I
and what this means immediately is that
if if we somehow knew that the social
sphere path length like basically the
the term on the right was small like was
I say like a monster constant then we
would be that right then the regret of
every player would be at most constant
right so effectively like the rvu bound
what it does is that it it like you know
it hints in the direction that maybe the
thing that you have to bound to bound
the regret is how much movement the
players uh you know just like can can
achieve
on the other hand you know like if you
send the regret uh this expression is
still valid
uh right like so for a constant Learning
grade you know you can still write this
thing about the social grid this is like
what we what we had in the in the
previous slide right so we said oh you
know like
you know if you throw away like the the
right term this is almost a constant but
if we don't throw away the the right
term the big idea is that you know if we
somehow knew that every player's regret
is not negative then you know from the
second uh equality you would have the
social path length is at most you know
just like Andover Ita and there's a that
is the most constant boost for the time
and so we could plug it back into the
first equality and have a constant
individual regrets alternatively another
way of saying this is that we know that
the sum of the regrets is the most
constant if we know that the regrets
also happen to be non-negative then you
know of course every regret also has to
be constant
this is all come from the first but it
comes from the rbu bound right I'm just
saying your rebound if you look at each
individual player can tell us the top
thing and if you look at the sum can
tell us the other thing right so I guess
like the idea is that if you know that
the sum of the regrets is non-negative
then from there you would be able to
kind of like switch kind of like the the
square the social Square path length to
the left hand side so that there is
constant and then plug it back into the
first mode
right but so again like I guess like uh
philosophy like the main takeaway is
maybe you know like you care about
um like if only we knew you know like
the uh the regrets were not negative or
the sum of the regrets would be not
negative uh either way we would have uh
you know constant regret perfectly
but which leads to the main question
which is you know can we somehow ensure
no negativity or player regrets while at
the same time not losing your view like
if this come like where the discount
like research started like they said
yeah that if somehow we can ensure the
negativity or play your regrets and not
lose your view bound that we're done
okay so now I guess like I'll talk a
little bit about the the way we achieve
this kind of like the negativity of
regrets
um and uh well first of all to not lose
the rpu bound perhaps it's not
surprising that our regrets are
like our Dynamics are based on
optimistic ftrl which is one of the two
classes of algorithms that are known
to have a rebound that one being
optimistic mirror descent uh right so we
use optimistic follow the regular Edge
leader uh but with three important
twists to kind of like ensure there's no
negativity of the regrets the first
twist is we use some lifting
um and what it means like what that
means is that
optimistic for the organized leader will
not operate on the set of strategies of
the player but rather on some lifted set
you know Moscow like x with the tilde
um right so tilde will always refer to
lifted quantities uh of course because
now we're operating in this lifted space
then feedback for the learning procedure
needs to also be lifted to this x still
there before the iterates can be
produced and I'll talk about how that
works uh that so that's like the first
two is the second twist is that we use a
very specific type of regularization
which is logarithmic regularization
um right and what that means is that for
the regularized leader uh will you know
like which is regularized we'll use kind
of like this log regularizer and one of
the uh I guess like interesting things
that happens is that this log
regularizer is not a log barrier for the
set right so we use a log regularizer
that is not a log barrier which is kind
of like puts us come like a little bit
outside of uh I guess like what people
usually do the other thing is that
lifting you know like the year of
lifting is kind of like very used in in
other contexts but as far as I'm aware
it's not really used to ensure the
negativity of regret so I feel like
that's also kind of like a kind of a
different thing
um so anyway so lifting block regular
conversation the third uh twitch that we
introduced is this idea of normalization
so because we're now operating on the on
the lifted space we somehow have to at
the end of the day like go back to
strategies for the original space and we
do that through uh normalization so you
know just like we have like discount
like pipeline where uh utilities come
into their webiniser they're first
lifted so they become all this then
they're fed into this optimistic for the
regular ice leader that is instantiated
with a log regularizer this produces
lifted strategies better than your
normal eyes to go back into real
strategies
okay so from now on I'll drop all the
subscripts that relate to players will
only be looking at regrets for one
player so you know like you can imagine
that all the quantities are per player
um without loss of generality we assume
that the uh set of strategies of the
player has already been shifted so that
uh like all the answers are not negative
uh right this will be important for the
log regularizer because like log of
negative numbers is not fine so
um right so we we first shift the set
this can be done without loss of
generality of course
um given any Vector X or like a strategy
X in in this in the set of strategies uh
or in fact really like any Vector we
don't know the kind of like indexing
into the vector with square brackets
otherwise there's like too many
subscripts and superscripts right so
square brackets mean like indexing and
vector and then we always assume that uh
the strategy set of a player uh never is
never become like flat with like one
coordinate always zero because I mean if
that was the case you could always drop
it without losing generality and again
this would cause problems when you have
log of zero right so we don't want that
all right perfect so let's just start
from the lifting so what does lifting of
the strategy set mean well it means that
we start from a strategy set which you
can imagine is like an RD and now we
construct a set X still there which is
in you know like r d plus one and what
we do it is that basically we take the
set we lift it and then we take this
kind of like truncated conical if you
want right so basically we took the set
we lifted so that we added one you know
extra coordinate which is always one and
then we took kind of like the interval
zero one times the set
okay so I guess pretorially if you want
to think about it this is something this
beginner
um cool so this is lifting of course
like we said you know like if we lift
your set of strategies then you also
have to have a plan for how to lift the
utilities or the feedback that you give
to the uh learning algorithm and uh you
know like the the lifting of the
strategies like sorry lifting of the
utilities giving that utility UT is
defined this way
right so basically we take UT and then
on top we stack the expected like the
inner product between uh the utility and
the last output strategy with a minus
sign and I guess like the only important
thing like that's why we do this is that
we can guarantee in particular that uh
the inner product between like the
lifted utility you told that and the
kind of like lifted strategy like where
you take you put the one and then the
past strategy you played is always zero
so like those two vectors are orthogonal
so that that tells us like the utilities
uh log regularization through the
logarithmic regularizer is like exactly
what you would imagine
um right so basically you just take
minus log of all the coordinates
it is a self-concordial function but
it's not a barrier for X soda so we'll
come back to that and then
clarification well what do you mean it's
not a barrier what is it
um it it just means that the basically
like the gradients of the localizer
don't go to Infinity on the boundary of
your invested right so normally when you
use like that kind of like the log
regularizer it happens to be uh kind of
like a barrier for your set so that then
when you take proximal steps you you
never go out but here we need to be
careful
um cool and then normalization what it
means is that after we produce a lifted
strategy which might be like a point I'm
like in the middle of this uh cone of
lifted uh strategies we need to kind of
like project it back or renormalize it
into a real strategy for the original
set and we do that by division
so basically we just kind of like draw a
line that connects the point until we
reached this kind of like playing at
Lambda is equal to one
okay perfect so with that I mean the
algorithm itself is incredibly simple
um right so we have basically you know
once like if you look at like five
groups of the utility we lift it and
like six we keep the tally that is
needed for optimistic Cloud regular is
leader on line seven and then online
three will produce the iterate using the
usual ftrl step and then in line four
which is normalized so nothing weird is
going on
so where does this work
um well
like interestingly I think uh the
lifting makes me written a negative uh I
think this is like basically the
probably like the biggest takeaway
um so in particular you know like if you
have regret on the original strategy
space and the regret on the lifted space
right which are kind of like writing the
definition of regret
um it turns out that there is a strong
relationship between the two and again
like remember that you know like the in
the two formulas like I'm assuming that
of course like the utility is like the
lifted of the utilities and
um XD is like normalization right so
there's like you know direct
correspondence between the the different
terms right there is a strong
relationship between regret and regret
tilde
any particular it turns out that Till
There is exactly equal to the max
between zero and regret
um right so this has two consequences
the first thing is that uh regret is
upper bounded by regretilda right
regretable domain the regret from the
lifted space which means that any
algorithm that guarantees more regret in
the lifted space automatically
guarantees more regret on uh on the
original space and the second thing is
of course uh like that result
immediately implies that regret tilde is
not negative
okay so at this point you might be
saying Okay and like we're gonna tell
there's a negative then we're done we
can just use the idea that we had before
but this is far from them right and and
you know like we have established a
negative regret in the lifted space but
we cannot invoke the result we mentioned
earlier and the reason is that the
utilities in the lifted space are not
lipsticks continuous with respect to the
strategies in the lifted space in
particular what we have is that the
utility in the lifted space our
lipsticks continuous in the strategy in
the original space
um and when the lambdas are very small
like those fractions can vary a lot so
if if you have that basically like your
Dynamics in the lifted space take you
very close to the origin then you don't
really know how to bound the kind of
like the utilities in different the
variation that you told us in in the way
that you need
okay so it's just because we have that
the lifted regret is the negative we're
far from them
um
and this is exactly where the choice of
uh using the log regularizer comes in
basically like the laboratorizer is
chosen exactly so that we can kind of
like transfer smoothness in the lifted
space uh to the original space
uh and in particular you know like uh
log regularizer uh you can prove that uh
enables this idea which is
multiplicative stability so
multiplicative stability what it means
is that the iterates that are produced
in the lifted space guarantee that
across successive iterations the in like
you know the ratio between the like the
components of of the strategies vary by
you know like relatively by at most
absolutely Sorry by most ether
um
right so you have that the ratio between
the lambdas and the Y's which are kind
of like the lifted strategies uh is
bounded between one manusita and one
plus
and uh you know like this comes uh from
the fact that uh you know like it's
known the Dynamics are locally stable
which means that in particular they're
stable with respect to the Hessian of
the regularizer and we chose the log
regularizer exactly because then the
Hessian is kind of like nicely one over
the square of the components so when you
plug the Hessian back into the local
stability condition then you end up with
something that looks exactly like
multiplicative stability so
multiplicative stability basically comes
from having chosen the localizer so that
the Hessian has this particular
structure and then knowing that follow
the regular's leader is locally stable
not just stable
foreign
descent the so often what happens
between mirror descent and father
recognized leader at least with lechon
regularizers is that you know like the
It rates are the same but in this case
because we don't really have a barrier
then we cannot really just say oh this
would be exactly the same it was
produced by emergency so you I think you
would need to kind of like touch on the
on the proofs a little bit to make it
work but I I would be surprised if this
didn't work for Mirror descent I guess
we just picked further recognized either
just I don't know I guess like I don't
know uh it seemed like easier to make it
work directly
cool right so right so multiplicative
disability like we said enables us to
transfer smoothness uh in the lifted
space uh like from the uh original Space
Racer we had that uh the in the lifted
space utilities were smooth with respect
to the uh strategies in the original
space but uh in particular you know like
because of the multiplicative stability
then we can you know just like there's
basically not much difference between
smoothness individual and in the lifted
space basically
um right so in particular we can
establish enough rebound for regret
tilde which is not negative that relates
to quantities in the original space
instead of of the lifted space
and uh from there like we said at this
point we can you know like carry out the
plan that we talked about right so and
this one we have bounded Social Security
path length because the regressional
negative and in turn because we don't
have a great deal they're also balance
the regret then we have the regret is
the most uh local negative
questions are kind of like all the kind
of like the different tools uh that are
used again like we have uh the lifting
to make their negative and
multiplicative stability to transfer
smoothness guarantees from the original
to the lifted space
and you know this is what the final red
bound looks like right so basically if
the step size is small enough with a
small enough means like a constant that
potentially uh might depend on the you
know the smoothness like the lip [ __ ]
constant the number of players the size
of the strategy set but anyway basically
like anything like if it is small enough
in a way that is time independent but
only game dependent then you can
guarantee that the regret of every
player isn't most a constant times log T
where again the constant Is Not Bent in
any way on like time on the side of the
game
right so once again you know like this
this is what like the different regret
uh bonds look like right like we get
this local T
um I'll like if you look carefully on in
the regret bounds like you will see that
you know like for example like log T is
better than put it like look the 40 into
the one fourth but
um the dependence on some of the other
game parameters is not as good as it
could be for example like in in normal
form games like we have for example that
uh
like our our Dynamics have a defactor
whereas if you look at an optimistic
multiplicity with a date like the second
line we have a log D Factor right so I
think it's like I'll talk about like
from the questions as to how like how
can we maybe improve this for special
cases so that we you know end up also
having like good dependence on say the
dimension of the set compared to other
methods
all right cool so
the last thing I want to talk about
um is
some details about implementation and
iteration complexity because so far you
know like we've just said okay we have
like these proximal steps that we take
in in photographers leader and then they
have multiplicative stability and we get
algorithmic regret
um
but
you know like this assumption that we
can make you know that we can actually
compute these proximal steps it's not
obvious especially for a convex compact
set expert which might be don't know I
think uh but also you know like there
are possible complications here
um the first thing is that the gradients
of the log regularizers
the bridge close to them but you know if
one entrance goes to zero then you log
of zero is like very big in absolute
value uh I guess log of something goes
to generate
um the log organizer is not a barrier
function which means that uh I guess I
keep coming back to this thing but you
know like what it means is that you have
to be careful about kind of like the
boundary all of a sudden like you know
just say oh you know just like I take a
step and as long as it's like it is
small enough I'm always inside like you
would do for example like like mutants
method with a barrier but I think the
biggest issue is you know what happens
to the guarantees especially like a
multiplicative stability if the
solutions to this optimization problem
are only approximated so I'd say that
we're only able to find a solution that
is closed you know like in the sense of
like the norm of the our solution to the
correct solution is small well that that
would be not enough because the whole
point of doing this uh optimistic FTL
would love randomizer is that we need to
guarantee multiplicative stability of
the interests that are produced over
time and that is known to hold for the
Exact Solutions but now if you have a
kind of like a additive perturbation
around that then my computer destroy all
the arguments right so this fact that
you know like we cannot just like settle
for an additive error bound on the kind
of like on how close we are to the exact
solution is a problem right because then
you know like when you combine these
three things it's not I think obvious
you know like how do you actually
compute this approximately
um
right so like I said you know we cannot
seek additive error guarantees
in particular what we need to do is we
need to you know seek relative or
multiplicative arrogantities basically
we need in turn to have that kind of
like the approximate solution which is
the ones at the top like Lambda and YT
compared to the exact solution which are
like the ones with the star are within a
factor Epsilon t
like multiplicatively like relatively uh
from each other
and uh once you have that you know it's
easy to see that as long as the approx
the relative approximation error is of
order one over T then uh the regret
degradation that you have from not using
Exact Solutions to your proximal step is
it most constant
and can we achieve all of this and it
turns out actually you know like I kind
of like set up for this like for being
complicated but one of the things that
surprised us is that it turns out that
we can achieve all these properties
efficiently by using a modification of
Newton's methods that enables quadratic
quality convergence
um and you know like that compared to
like for example like the usual Newton
method like holds even if a regularizer
is not a sub component there right so
actually we
it took some time to finally complete
this last piece because like they were
like so many obstacles but actually it's
surprisingly simple it turns out that
there exists modifications of Newton
method that um guarantee you know that
we can achieve all of this even for this
log regularizer which is not available
[Music]
[Music]
right so depending on the center at
which you're trying to evaluate the the
proximal step you might have that the
quadratic term changes right so it's not
like a dynamic uh quadratic Channel
right more I guess like concretely
basically you have to like as long as
you're able to compute Solution on your
lifted set of
complex like strictly convertible like
stronger complex problems of of the form
in the second line of this form then uh
what we show is that uh we can basically
they in log of tea time preparation you
can actually compute this approximate
solutions that you need for the proximal
step
so in particular in normal form games
it's expensive from games we actually
showed that this local proximate Oracle
can be uh constructed uh right so we
actually have uh you know just a
constructed one did like the experiments
that you saw earlier
um they were using that uh
uh you know that Oracle
um and uh of course like you know one we
need to check that this or holding
because we actually constructed them and
constructing people normal time right so
like you can find an exact solution of
this uh local proximal problem like this
kind of like linear plus quadratic term
uh in normal form and extensive form
strategy spaces people in no time
right and when we do that uh we can then
invoke you know like the I guess the
idea of like using uh Newton with local
proximal oracles I mean that's not
that's not ours like we uh learned from
uh this this other paper by trending
um and basically what it turns out is
that as long as you have the local
proximal Oracle then you can compute uh
you know like good like good approximate
Solutions so like with relative Epsilon
approximation to your fql problem using
log log one over approximation uh
operations and local one approximation
calls to local production protocols
right so this explains uh the log log T
per iteration complexity that I promised
for uh these learning dynamics that
we've been proposing
okay so last thing so what if we do not
know how to construct a local proximal
Oracle for set X down right like you
could imagine that I mean as I said you
know for normal form and extension form
games we know how to construct this
proximal records for intervals it would
be easy but maybe your favorite uh
convex game has a set of strategies X
for which you don't know how to
construct a person Oracle well the good
news is that uh you can implement the
method correctly which means like you
can guarantee this kind of like relative
uh approximation
um
to the steps of for the garage leader
even only if you have linear
optimization articles which means like
if the only thing that you can do is how
to maximize linear functions on your set
of strategies X then there is enough to
still retain log T guarantees even when
you factor in the approximation
guarantee the approximation of the like
follow recognize leader steps and in
particular we use another uh tool this
one's from like a recent paper by new at
all
um that is called Frank Wolf Newton and
effectively you know like the the
guarantees look look like this so if you
want to achieve relative action
approximation for your ftrl problem and
you only have access to linear
optimization Oracle then as long as you
are willing to pay polynomial in one of
our Epsilon operations and polynomial in
One Direction calls to a linear position
or holding your your good
so it's just to compare this to what you
had to face like with point of view you
uh so they have correlation complexity
of B and yours is log log T times
quality the constant is
right exactly exactly yeah yeah that's
yeah
uh right so I'll talk a little bit about
yeah exactly like comparison with OMW
and whether these Dynamics
can be improved like if you know that
you're for example dealing with a normal
from game in particular like can you
take the same ideas of lifting and an
active regret but package it in a way
that's normal form game specific so that
you can like somehow gain just like log
d uh cost for example like determine the
the dependence in the regret uh as
opposed to Quality and also like more
favorable uh complexity per iteration
these would be the number of actions
now what is I think it's like d to the
three
yeah it's not it's not something crazy
like in the 75 or something but uh and
we've we've been implementing this in
like in in relatively large games so so
this thing can scale
um to some extent but
um yeah like definitely compared to
multiplicative ways I mean
multiplicative ways it's also like way
easier to implement right you just have
to do like uh exponentiation uh whereas
here you have like all this trickiness
of the local proximal uh Newton and a
little bit but anyway so like zooming
out
one of the important takeaway messages
so the first thing is that we developed
this uh learning dynamics that are
uncoupled such that when all players in
a general convex game employ these
Dynamics the regret of each player grows
only logarithmically in time
this significantly extends and
strengthens the scope of all player work
um and one of the nice features also
this which I have not talked about but
um actually before that like also our
couple learning Dynamics can be
efficient implemented using for example
proximo protocol for the underlying
visible set we showed level of t one
other feature that is nice about these
Dynamic process that and have not talked
about this but is the fact that you know
you can modify them slightly so that
they gracefully uh can like fall back on
giving uh say square root of T regret if
they figure out that the environment
actually is adversarial and not
everybody is doing so play right so
there you can use them as kind of like
Drop in learning algorithms or whatever
like setting you are you're looking at
and they will fall back naturally
there are some open questions
um I guess like this kind of like a very
active area research and of course like
what we know is still like a fraction of
what we would want to know
um but let me just like note some some
questions here so in the special case of
normal form games the dependence on the
dimension of our of our Dynamics is
linear as opposed to logarithmic uh
right like in optimistic multiplicative
weights
so like a natural question is you know
like can we improve that for example
like if we if we looked at uh like we
know that we're only working on normal
phone games can we somehow just like
leveraged in our Dynamics the other
question uh that again relates to
optimistic movability with update is uh
there they use entropubularization which
is like an easier tool to work with
unfortunately the Hessian of
interoperative regularization is not
powerful enough to achieve multiple
negative stability or at least we don't
know how to to do it
um in like for General sets so a
question like a natural question is can
entropriate regularization be
incorporated into our framework as
opposed to log regularization which you
know like as you can imagine like blog
regularization because it you know like
given just like the range of the log
function can be Infinity close to the
boundary it poses a lot of like other
problems so
you know it can be somehow maybe
switched in traffic recognization
difficulties
um right implementation difficulty of
entropic would be let's see how it's
applies right like also because the at
least like phenomenal from games if you
use entropy the approximal steps have a
closed form solution that is very easy
to compute for example for the log
regularizer uh you will need to do this
kind of like mute and Method basically
then what's the thing is the stability
what's missing yeah so if you're trying
to use entropy regularization and the
argument like in kind of like the
structure of the of the forget analysis
that I showed you like the the place
where things break is the modern
negative stability because the
multiplicative stability depended on the
Hessian strategies
right right like the multiplicative
stability in the lifted space like if
the lifted strategies right like the
their the the way we obtain their
multiplicatives to be able to guarantee
was because we know that follow the
regularized leader is uh it's kind of
like stable in local norm and the local
Norm induced by the local regularizer is
like the diagonal of one over x squared
so when you just kind of expand this
definition you basically end up with
squares from the top that depend on on
the strategy variation and then at the
bottom which depends on the Hessian of
the regularizer and because they have
square square you can just kind of like
put them together and good things happen
but if you use entropy regularization
the Hessian is not one over x i squared
but it's rather one over x side whereas
you don't have the square the
denominator and this you know like at
this point you don't know exactly what
to do foreign
cool right so so I guess like yeah that
was like another question like can we
use entrepreneur recognization another
question is uh
what can be said about different uh
types of vocals
one natural question is you know can we
use separation oracles instead of like
Global proximals or linear organization
articles and if so it seems like
um the ellipsoid algorithm could be like
at least theoretically uh like uh kind
of like a Natural Choice then to
implement uh the proximal steps that you
need for ftrl in uh like in our Dynamics
and then sounds like very fundamental
questions you know like is all of T per
player really the best that we can do in
convex games or in all convex games or
you know like what is uh is there like a
matching lower bound
and uh beyond that you know like if we
go beyond uh external regret like what
happens about like what happens in swap
regret say you want to convert
equilibrium uh enamel from games or what
happens to five regret in accessible
games like say maybe you want to
converge to extensive form according to
equilibrium so we're doing some work in
that direction
um some of the ideas here can be
generalized for uh fiberg which in turn
also you know like as a specialization
implies results for swap regret
um so there is something that can be
said here but I feel like definitely
with not seen the the end of this uh you
know it would be very nice if you know
somebody could develop like nice you
know just like simple simplement
Dynamics or maybe like it turns out that
optimistic multiplicative weights
already is the the all the Dynamics that
we need uh and and just like we're just
like one regret analysis away uh from
just like getting where we want to get
anyway so that's it um you know I have
to take any questions and you know like
if you prefer I'm also very happy to
talk more via email
yeah I guess